hey guys it's Jonah here so imagine this
you just had a really solid workout
session and you feel satisfied with how
much you have pushed yourself so you go
to bed and the next morning when you try
to get up oh my god your leg muscles are
so sore you can barely walk so you'd sit
there struggling to get by the next few
days and you can't even get back into
your fitness routine what you're
experiencing is called
delay onset muscle soreness also known
as Dom's Dom's is caused by microscopic
tearing of the muscle fibers that are
then repaired as part of the muscle
growth process the soreness is felt most
strongly between 24 to 72 hours after
exercising Dom's is extremely common
especially if you're new to exercising
if you change your workout routine or if
you dramatically increase the intensity
and duration of your exercise so
beginners there is nothing to worry
about
post-workout muscle soreness is part of
muscle adaptation and muscle development
it is something anyone and everyone who
has ever worked out can relate to so the
most common question is can I avoid
Dom's
altogether what to simply put the answer
is known but there are steps which you
can take to reduce and prevent Dom's and
also to help your muscles recover
quicker so the first tip is stretch at
the end of your workouts well there has
been a lot of debate in regards to
whether or not stretching at the end of
your workout will help to reduce muscle
soreness when you train you contract the
muscles as a result the muscle fibers
will get shorter and tighten up when you
stretch it will help to lengthen the
muscles it will relieve the feeling of
tightness and promote the better muscle
recovery if however you find yourself
disagreeing - this will just put it this
way stretching also helps with
flexibility and we want that so there is
no harm to include a quick 10 to 15
minutes of stretching after a good solid
workout the second tip is to soak in a
warm bath warm water can increase blood
flow and help loosen up tight or sore
muscles but do not jump into the hot tub
immediately after your workouts when
your body heat is already high and your
muscles are breaking down soaking in a
hot tub immediately will only further
damage your muscles so take a warm bath
once you have cooled down and your body
has written to its resting temperature
if your pen is isolated what you can do
is to apply direct hit to the spot by
using peel and stick on heat pads the
next tip is to massage your sore spots
so getting a message isn't just about
pampering yourself it can help to
promote blood flow and to ease tight
muscles so it can help to speed up
muscle recovery so if you can go for a
light and gentle massage not the rough
kind okay rough massages can sometimes
only further injure your muscles
remember that messages should somewhat
be relaxing and you shouldn't be in
constant pain if however you can't get
messages then invest in a foam roller
the foam roller works similar to massage
by increasing blood flow to your muscles
and the best part is it is cheap easy to
use and you can do it on your own foam
rolling involves a technique called
self myofascial release which uses
pressure and targets of the connective
tissue covering the muscles so put the
roller on the floor use your body weight
to apply pressure and roll back and
forth over the soil areas for about one
minute if this is your first time doing
it just take it easy and eventually you
will get the hang of it remember before
doing that check that your rehydrated
and that your heart rate is back to
normal when your muscles are hot and
loaded with lattic acid you can only
make it worse the next tip is to pack on
omega-3s when your muscles are sore your
muscles are basically inflamed omega-3s
are known to help reduce inflammation so
pack on food which are rich in omega
threes such as salmon oily fish chia
seeds flax seeds avocado spinach walnut
or edamame or for convenience you can
even take fish oil pills on a daily
basis and another very important tip is
to get plenty of rest as much as you
want to push yourself in your workouts
getting plenty of rest is just as
important that means getting al
is six to eight hours of sleep every
night and giving yourself at least one
full rest day a week when you don't get
enough rest it will not only affect your
fitness performance but your muscles
will also recover slower so prioritize
your sleep as much as you prioritize
your workouts and the final tip is move
it when your muscles are so sorry you
can barely walk or even get out of bed
you are more inclined just to sit on the
couch and pray that the pain will go
away well that is the last thing you
should be doing just know this
circulation promotes healing and if
you're just set on the couch doing
absolutely nothing the blood in your
body will not be able to flow hence you
will not recover what you should be
doing is to continue your workout
through active recovery it is basically
low intensity exercises just to get the
blood in your body flowing without
texting the muscles so think of gentle
yoga classes brisk walking an easy hike
or even a relaxing swim you can do this
the next day after an intense session or
even for a couple more days if your
muscles are extremely sore so guys my
recommendation is to alternate your
workout intensity so for instance
alternate between two days of high
intensity with two days of moderate
intensity and two days of low intensity
this will ensure that you are getting
the best result through your workouts
and that your body is still getting
plenty of time to recover and remember
when you experience post workout muscle
soreness the goal is to increase blood
flow into your muscles and to relieve
the feeling of tightness wanting to
achieve great fitness result isn't just
about the training aspect it includes
eating well and getting plenty of rest
when you're able to find that balance
not only will you be able to train
stronger for longer you will also see
results in the most efficient way if you
find this video to be helpful be sure to
like it and share it as well all the
best
you